lié à ce que vous connaissez le dame
tout qu'au site aden ce challenge non
non non non pour les plus jeunes gilles
à la reconnaissance non pas du tout
c'est très simple c'est un nouveau
phénomène sur internet c'est un
challenge qui cartonne sur les réseaux
way but est simple il faut reproduire
les pas de ces tayeb louh a aidés à nous
alors on a demandé à des poteaux autour
de la table de participer eux aussi à ce
challenge
chebbi a gentiment accepté maxime aussi
merci poteau regardez notre top 3 y en a
eu d'autres
troisième de ce classement c'est maxime
justement sur les bien sorti
[Musique]
c'est pas mal deuxième tu lis hyper sexy
envers elle a tout donné un grand merci
elle peut participer à danse avec ready
jet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'attends d'abord on avait le gagnant du
jour c'est benji le black rade tpt noté
l'aisance et la grâce reid et tu oses
étoiles
[Applaudissements]
visite guidée sam est bien pour lundi on
pour incruster ce qu'on veut sur ce
corps